This is a typical New York city Avenue.
The New York city sidewalk cafe initiative has allowed us to take over a
lane of traffic on either side and put in sidewalk cafe.
Hi, I'm Sterling planter. I'm a restaurant and retail architect.
I've worked on the design of all of these restaurants.
I I'm going to talk about restaurant design here in New York city with COVID
restriction.
Before we get into the details of how restaurants have responded to the COVID
virus, we need to get into the design of restaurants,
pre COVID New York city restaurants are long narrow spaces,
typically because they're taking up the base of a tenement building.
This is a typical New York city restaurant floor plan.
They tend to be 20 to 25 foot wide,
60 to 80 foot long,
and have many obstacles that reduce that with even further,
including staircases elevators, service stores,
hallways, which can reduce the width down to roughly 15 feet.
So then COVID hit the typical restaurant that we just walked through,
suddenly lost all of its occupancy.
So pre COVID our restaurant,
which had 40 persons able to dine in the restaurant has been reduced to 10
persons. They are however allowed to expand into a lane of traffic,
which allows them to add 16 persons depending on the size of their space.
Pre COVID a restaurant's goal was to look full, to look inviting,
to look like a space that a person wants to go and dine in.
That's completely appended. Now, now you need a place that looks safe to go,
which is a different environment. You don't want a restaurant.
That's packed with people in doors.
You want a restaurant that feels like they're taking your safety seriously,
which means the outdoor dining is separated in July of this year.
New York city released guidelines for how a restaurant can expand onto the
streets. This is New York city's guideline diagram, a building,
which has a frontage, which is the width of their storefront.
Can then do a restaurant out on the street for outdoor dining,
with some exceptions. So in the beginning there were makeshift structures.
So these restaurant designs are simple, quick,
effective ways to define a space simply created using
construction,
pallets tent structures to keep the weather out tables are spaced
six feet apart.
A raised floor allows for ADA access safety barrier elements
that protect your patrons from traffic and the adjacent spaces.
So the challenge of this first phase of outdoor sidewalk dining is
that if you have a car directly adjacent to somebody sitting at a
table having dinner, it's not a very nice environment.
It doesn't feel like a safe, comfortable to eat.
You're mixing their exhaust smoke with your fine dining
experience.
Mayor DeBlasio announced that sidewalk dining would become a permanent element
of New York city. In this next phase,
restaurant tours had figured out a couple of ways to enhance their space,
very inexpensively, including adding landscaping along the perimeter,
barricade. This served the purpose of softening the structures as well as
providing that respite from New York city traffic exhaust another one of the
challenges of New York city restaurant.
The New York city street tends to be Arctic so that water drains into the
gutters. And it's really not that pleasant to be at a table.
That's sitting on an angle by adding a floor that's flush with the sidewalk.
You end up with a straight flat surface that is ADA accessible and makes for a
better dining experience. So these structures really only work in good weather.
Nobody wants to sit out on the street when it's raining out.
Sidewalk cafes have been very successful over the summer here in New York city,
but now we're moving into the fall and winter months when the temperature is
dropping, the question becomes,
how do you winterize an outdoor sidewalk cafe while meeting the rules of
COVID? So in New York city, in winter,
you're going to have rain coming from above.
You're going to have wind blowing from the sides, water,
and ice and snow building up on the streets.
So you're making a contained environment that shields you from these elements.
We start adding elements like roofs.
You end up adding walls and then clear vinyl sheets.
So what you have to be careful not to do is fully enclosed.
The outdoor environment, basically building a building on the street.
You need to keep at least 50% of your area of
walls and ceilings open. Usually one facade facing the restaurant.
This gives you the dual purpose of getting the airflow,
but also the people in the restaurant servers, wait,
staff can see everybody in there and take care of them.
They're not hidden behind a wall.
If you fully enclose your outdoor dining space,
it's no different than an indoor restaurant at that point.
So in the case of this greenhouse type structure,
this becomes indoor dining, New York city said,
you can do that on the street as well,
but then you have to follow the rules of indoor dining tables need to be a
certain distance apart. You only have 25% occupancy.
So the goal of this next phase of sidewalk cafes it's to make a
pleasant experience of outdoor dining,
similar to what you had pre COVID indoor dining it's to make it year round
dining,
a space that people are comfortable going in mid summer or mid winter equally.
Well.
And it's basically to allow restaurant tours to have enough tables to keep
in business, to get through the end of this crisis.
The outdoor dining initiative in New York city has been phenomenally successful
prior to COVID. There were 24,000 restaurants approximately in New York city.
Since New York city instituted the outdoor dining over 10,000 of them have
opened up outdoor dining spaces.
Now I'm going to walk you through the restaurant design pre and post COVID.
You start out on the street, storefront signage.
That's your first experience of the restaurant. As you walk in,
how you're greeted is your second part of the experience,
then you actually get to sit at your table and your experience is taken over by
the food, the atmosphere and the service in the restaurant.
So post COVID the experience of walking up to a restaurant is very different.
You need to socially distance,
you've got your six foot space decals on the street.
The dots that have been put on sidewalks and everything else around the city are
fairly effective. When you come in, you no longer see diners right away.
What you see as a host stand with takeout instructions.
So you're picking up orders, having food to go.
Part of the signage package that's involved in a restaurant now are things like
face covering requirements. How you go to the bathroom in a restaurant,
what the rules are when you're in the restaurant.
So these photos are of restaurants, obviously pre COVID,
which show the activity. The interaction of people.
The primary directive is to get the people at the tables that are able to be
seen from the exterior food and beverages,
both look better under natural light post COVID.
You're going to have far fewer people.
You're going to lose every other table here.
Many restaurants have introduced signage on the tables,
which includes things like QR codes for the menus.
One of the main advantages to restaurants that this is brought out is they can
now change their menu on a daily basis without having to reprint reformat their
menus everything's on the phones.
So that's how the restaurant experience has changed post COVID. Now,
I'm going to talk about the future of dining in New York city.
So as we move into the next phase of sidewalk, cafes,
New York can learn a lot from European cities.
Well outdoor dining in New York city and taking back streets from vehicular
traffic is something new for us in Europe. It's been happening for years.
European cities have plazas sidewalks,
all filled with outdoor dining and seating situations.
It's part of the urban fabric of those cities. And it's very successful.
It makes the streets safer.
It makes them more active and it extends the life of those sidewalks and cafes
further into the evening or earlier in the morning,
because it's part of the cityscape.
So some of the things we can learn from European cities and how they interact
with their outdoor dining is that it doesn't have to be an interference in the
sidewalk or streetscape.
In some cases they've extended the storefront out onto the street or
sidewalk. They've allowed it to be part of the restaurant,
just an outdoor portion of it.
And similar to what we're doing here in New York city,
they've created platforms that are separate from the restaurant and the sidewalk
goes between them.
Some of the more successful restaurants have faced all of the seats towards the
street. It becomes an interactive viewing, almost like theater.
Some of the streets in Europe that are most famous for doing this are the,
the Elisa in Paris or Loram Los in Barcelona, where having sidewalk,
cafes and dining has not only become a draw for it.
It's become a tourist attraction in its own. Right?
One of the big design challenges in New York city is that we don't have service
ways or alleyways behind the buildings, any sidewalk, cafes,
or outdoor dining that we design are going to have to compete with those
services for space on the street.
COVID is accelerated program in New York city called open streets,
treats closed or mostly closed for [inaudible] traffic.
Opening them up for pedestrians and non vehicular uses.
New York city had 87 separate open street designations
spread throughout the city.
So this is what a New York city open street might look like.
You've got sidewalk dining on either side, you've opened up to pedestrians.
It becomes like a block party. That's permanent.
What the future might hold is a full greening of New York city,
where it's not just closing down a couple streets and putting in painted
plazas. You add green scape. You add trees,
you add landscaping and New York city becomes a much greener and
friendlier place to be.
The overall effect of this would be turning avenues in New York city into linear
parks. Similar to the highlight
Going by the numbers.
New York city restaurants are definitely in trouble due to COVID.
They've been closed down for many months.
Estimates are approximately 40% of the restaurants in New York city will not
make it through this crisis.
Architects and designers are assisting restaurants as quickly as possible to
help them make these cafes work, make sidewalk, cafes, winterized,
and be able to work year round and become a permanent part of the New York city
streetscape.
The COVID has obviously been a horrendous impediment to restaurants in New York
city. However, there is a silver lining despite the tragedy of the disease.
It has allowed us to help reshape the city and how
residents and tourists visiting it, interact.
With the environment.